my relationship with Hawaii you know
starts from the beginning I was born and
raised here so basically when they say
you know you're a product of your
environment I'm a direct product of my
environment
it's gonna be interesting I think you
know the feeling you get in wearing a
suit is very empowering already so when
you're riding who knows it might just be
the secret little weapon you might just
feel so good that you're just gonna be
throwing down moves that you maybe
normally wouldn't
now this town is very special to me
this is idea town
has that classic small-town feel you
know after being in the big cities
around the world nothing like coming
home to my little town it's so similar
to other small towns around the country
and little differences that we're here
on Maui and in the Pacific
I have never worn a suit while kite
boarding windsurfing or any sort of
water sport land of going so fast I land
on chocolate just explosion of white
water what is funny cause like I was
like stuff that landing
I hope you're having fun with me because
there's a lot more to come
subscribe to GQ do you want to see me
break in the zoo always serving instead
of out of winning check out these videos